- I had some health issues when
I was younger with my heart.
I am grateful many mornings I wake up.
I say this to people all the time,
I've been happy rich and
I've been happy poor.
Happy rich is better.
Successful people and wealthy people
have a subtle distinction.
They don't look at price.
They look at worth.
- Need motivation?
- Watch a top 10 with Believe Nation.
- What's up Believe Nation, it's Evan.
I believe in you and
this channel is designed
to be a part of your
daily success routine.
So let's get your motivation to a 10
and get you believing in you.
Grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a man who went from being
born in a middle class family
to building one of the most successful
financial services company in the world.
And be one of the top motivational
speakers on the planet.
He's Ed Mylett and here's my take
on his top 10 rules to success volume two.
(upbeat music)
Okay let's kick it off with
rule number one, grow you.
- I don't believe in
faking it 'til you make it.
Because you know what
entrepreneurialism is right?
It's the greatest self-discovery process
in the history of mankind.
Isn't it?
You learn more about yourself.
What you don't know, your
resiliency, how tough you are,
what your weaknesses are,
by being an entrepreneur.
It's probably the greatest
self-discovery program
in the history of the world.
It's also this, it's the
greatest self-improvement program
with the highest compensation
package possibly attached
to it too.
Entrepreneurism is a
self-improvement program
with massive compensation
package attached to it.
And that's why too many
of you are too focused
on growing your company
and not focused enough on growing you.
Because your company will
never ever exceed your identity
or your vision for it.
You got to grow you
because what'll happen
when it starts to grow,
you'll start making unconscious
mistakes to shrink it.
Making bad calls, getting weak,
getting lazy, making mistakes.
You're all nodding because
you've all done it,
because at some point your
business got ahead of you.
It will never exceed your
identity and your vision.
Because if the company
catches your vision,
the company catches your
identity, you're dying.
- Rule number two, be
in a state of gratitude.
- I'm grateful that I have the money
for the plane tickets still.
- Right.
- It's odd how small things,
I love big things, I love having my jet,
but I make sure that I'm grateful for what
most people will think are small things.
And I really am.
I had some health issues when
I was younger with my heart.
I am grateful many mornings I wake up.
My day starts with gratitude,
I'm awake many, many mornings.
And so that's a center piece of my life.
It's odd because I have
all these things in my head
from when I was a kid,
gratitude is sort of the antidote
for everything not good in my life.
- Rule number three, care about people.
- What would you say is
your greatest asset, skill?
- I love people, man.
I care about people, I sincerely do.
And so, whether that's, yeah,
I mean I want to help you.
People say, how do you get back
to all these people on social media?
I care, you know.
- Yeah, it's a lot, yeah.
- You and I have talked about that fact.
My intent is good, man.
I want to make a difference in the world.
We're all put here for a reason.
It sounds hokie.
I've made a lot of money.
I'd like to make more
money but it's not really
a driver for me.
- [Interviewer] Right.
You've got a bunch of homes.
- I've filled that need.
It's not long lasting.
No material thing I've
ever required was as cool
as I thought it would be.
It's cool.
- It's cool for a week or two.
- Exactly.
- And then you're like now what?
- Now what, right?
It's empty.
By the way, I think
everybody should have a jet
if they can have one.
Everybody ought to have
unicorn in their waterfall.
Everybody ought to live oceanfront.
I say this to people all the time,
I've been happy rich and
I've been happy poor.
Happy rich is better.
Don't let anybody tell you
happy rich ain't better
than happy poor.
Trust me.
It's better.
And money's a magnifier.
If you're a really good person.
You get a bunch of money.
It's probably going to
magnify your generosity
and your kindness and your patience.
And if you're a curmudgeon
and mean and hurt people
money's going to magnify that too.
So I'd rather have a bunch of money.
Hands down.
Right?
But it's not something that drives me
in my life.
It doesn't fulfill me.
- Rule number four, stop
negotiating the price.
- When I was poor, everywhere I went
I flipped the price tag over.
What's it cost?
I was constantly negotiating
the price for everything
in my life.
You do that when you come
from a place of scarcity,
of being poor.
Successful people and wealthy people
have a subtle distinction.
They don't look at price.
They look at worth.
Is this worth it?
If you're constantly
looking at the price tag,
you'll eventually relent.
You'll eventually give in.
Stop negotiating the price.
It's a freeing experience
to totally commit.
When you totally commit to a relationship,
to a business, to your
fitness, to your faith.
It's a freeing powerful.
It's almost like removing kryptonite
from your life, when you totally commit.
Can you do that?
The people around you, always
say it's costing too much,
it's costing too much.
And you're going, maybe
You've got to start
going, no, it's worth it.
It's not the price, it's the worth.
It's a subtle distinction in your life.
- Rule number five, have persistence.
- You've been very successful
as an entrepreneur.
Have you always been successful?
- You just said the word
entrepreneur and always successful.
- Thank you, listen to him.
I try to tell everybody this.
Nobody listens to me.
I've haven't met one
entrepreneur that's like oh yeah,
everything I have ever done works.
- Come on, bro.
- And they're lying if they tell you that.
- Well they're not an entrepreneur.
They've inherited
something or I don't know.
- Right, mostly inherited.
- Right.
Because if you're an
entrepreneur, you have not always
been successful, right?
- From Steve Jobs down.
- All the way.
And so I've had successes
and then I'll go backwards.
Like most entrepreneurs,
there's false start after
false start after false start.
So I would get it going and
then it would go backwards.
I'd save some money, then I'd blow it.
My business would grow,
then it would shrink.
No, I've had tons of different financial
events happen in my life.
And actually after people
thought I was pretty successful,
I'd become a millionaire,
about 26 years old.
I'd become a millionaire.
I was making a million
dollars a year and I ended up
losing it all.
It ended up, I lost a home, I lost a car.
I ended up moving into an apartment.
I was newly married and
I'll never forget this.
I remember because this ocean's out there.
We're looking at it right now.
I remember honestly, a defining moment.
I had everything turned off.
You can have power turned
off and still survive.
One thing I learned, you don't
want your water turned off.
And we have the water cut off.
- With your newlywed.
- My newlywed.
Six weeks married.
- Is she still with you?
- She's still with me.
She's floating around here somewhere.
- That's it man.
- She's with me.
- We've got so much in common.
- I know we do.
Both high school and the
same thing with our wives.
And long story short, we
had to go every morning
out of the apartment, go down to the pool
and shower outdoors.
And we'd bring our toothbrush.
It was just shameful for me.
- Rule number six, keep the
promises you made to you.
- The key to self-confidence
is really simple.
This is absolutely, I've
trained hundreds of thousands
of people, I've spoken to millions
of people around the world.
I can tell you this, the
self-confident people I know,
whether they are athletes,
school teachers, mechanics,
parents, stay-at-home moms,
you name it, they have
a pattern of keeping promises
they make to themselves.
The ground work of beginning
to build self-confidence
is to begin to keep the
promises you make to you
and that's why it's important to begin
to even make small promises.
If you're going to get up at
a certain time in the morning,
not only do it but then
give yourself credit.
Say, I did what I said I was going to do.
If it's in your diet or your fitness,
don't just eat the healthy
foods, go, I'm doing what
I said I was going to do.
You begin to build this reputation.
If you're constantly being
influenced and moved by
what other people think about you,
it means there's a deficiency
in what you think about you.
And so the key is not some
esoteric belief system,
it's a pattern of keeping the
promises that you make to you.
That's the groundwork of self-confidence.
For sure and it is a pattern.
When I meet people that
lack confidence, I think
let me serve you, let's
begin to keep the promises
you make to you.
You're so worried about,
there's this addiction to other
people's approval in the world.
- Right.
- Right?
The greatest addiction
today, it used to be drugs.
Before that it was alcohol.
There's all these addictions,
sex addictions, whatever.
The number one addiction
in the world today
is the addiction to
other people's approval
and that's because we
don't approve of ourselves
or we don't feel a spirit, a universe,
a God that we believe
in that approves of us.
And so my confidence
comes from both my faith
and in the fact that I keep
promises I make to myself.
That's the groundwork of all confidence.
- Rule number seven, max out your life.
- See at the end of my
life, the Lord's going to go
hey by the way, this guy over here,
this is the man you could have been.
This is the person you were born to be.
This would have been your dreams.
This is where you would have
gone, what you would have seen,
who you would've helped,
what you would've changed.
This would've been your book.
Meet him.
My dream in my life is that
when I meet that person
we're not total strangers.
You don't want to get
to the end of your life
and that character is a
total stranger to you.
You know damn well there's
going to be a funeral
for you some day.
At that funeral, there's going
to be a sense and a spirit
of what you could have become.
The woman, the man you could
have become and every day
those decisions you're
making to max out your life
are chasing that person.
See you know what I want
at the end of my life
when I meet him?
I want to be identical twins.
Ted and Ed are going to meet
each other some day and I'm
going to say hey man, good to see you.
I've been chasing you man.
He's going to go, I've been watching you.
You're exactly like me, man.
We're identical twins.
You maxed out your damn life.
Congratulations.
- Rule number eight, get quiet.
- I believe everything has a vibration.
And so everything has an energy, right.
And so that, I have, without
getting too complicated,
I have to quiet myself because
when I get quiet I vibrate
at a higher frequency.
And so that I can tap into,
see the same thought, the same
energy that made this
ocean, that made the world,
that made you and I, I have
access to that limitless,
absolutely perfect thinking in mind.
And so the only way that I get that
is by getting out of my own way,
getting out of my own space,
getting out of my own junk.
And so I access it from
me by getting quiet.
The key to my life is that,
in the morning and I do
it in the morning, it's
nice now that I can do it
with the ocean here.
I also live on a lake.
Is I just, and it doesn't
take a long time, I just take
20 minutes and I access
it and I get quiet.
And the only way I can
access it is to get out of my
head and so I quiet and empty my mind
and I access the universe.
That's what I do.
- Rule number nine, hustle.
- Mom and dad work?
- Mom worked in the home.
Raised four kids.
My dad worked in a bank.
Very successful executive in a bank.
- Okay, were you learning
something from him about
being an executive?
- No.
- Dressing or money?
- I learned about my dad real simple.
Hustle and busting ass.
So my dad was up before
I was up in the morning,
out of the house.
My dad would get home when it was dark.
I watched my dad bust his tail.
I watched my dad work Saturdays.
- And then he came and
had a couple cocktails.
- He did for a long time
and that was probably,
by the way, why he was coming
home so late for awhile.
But in my mind and even after
he became sober, like a lot
of men of that generation, my
dad just busted his damn tail.
I think it's almost a lost art form
with younger guys today, right?
My dad just flat busted it.
Now he busted it 'cause
he's just trying to provide
limiting things like food and shelter.
He never thought about
big things or dreams
or getting wealthy or having influence.
He just wanted to survive.
- And rule number 10, the
last one before a very
special bonus clip, is
talk about your dreams.
- So this was my dream place to live.
All my life I wanted to live
in Laguna Beach, California
in Three Arch Bay.
I wanted to live in Coeur
d'Alene, Idaho and I wanted
to be able to play golf out
in the beautiful dessert
in Palm Dessert.
I live in those dream places
and one of the reasons
I live there is because I talked
about my dream early in my life.
There's power to just talking
about, just telling people,
just putting in writing
what your dream is.
And so I'm curious, do this for me.
Comment below right here and
tell me and tell the world
where you dream place to live is.
What's your dream place to live?
I want to see your comments below.
- Now I've got a really
special bonus clip with Ed
talking about how to always aim for more
that I think you're going to really enjoy.
But before that, it's time
for the three point landing questions.
Time to move from watching
another video to actually
taking action in your
life, in your business.
So here we go.
Question number one,
what's one promise you made
to yourself that you need to keep?
Number two, what does a maxed
out life look like to you?
And number three, what is your dream?
Talk about it below.
- One of my top guys at
our firm a few weeks ago,
one of my favorite people,
probably one of the most
talented guys in my company.
I won't say who he is
'cause he might be watching
this but he said that to me.
He goes I just wanted to
share with the world how
amazing and incredible my
life is and blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah and I told him, I
said when I was at your level,
I couldn't stomach it,
I couldn't handle it.
I couldn't live on that kind of income.
I didn't want to live my
life like that and it scares
me that you think somehow
this is the dream.
And of course he kind of
corrected himself and backstopped
but the fact is I'm
constantly deceiving myself.
I really do feel that way.
I really don't feel successful.
I don't think I'm a failure
but I do measure it up
against the highest version
of me, my highest expression.
- As opposed to what?
As opposed to measuring
yourself against what?
- Other people.
That's the biggest thing people do.
They're so obsessed with other people.
It kills them and they think about
what are they thinking about me?
What are they going to think about me?
What are they saying?
And then they measure themselves
against other people too.
I've been around you, you're
a powerhouse but neither
one of us, you were talking
about Einstein at the break,
neither one of us have a
super, crazy off-the-charts IQ.
I sure know you don't so I'm
going to talk to you first.
- Now you see, you've done
that a couple times now.
He keeps taking shots at me.
- Well it's obvious, they're watching,
they know, they see you.
No, but the fact of the
matter is you didn't get where
you are because of some
gifted gigantic intellect.
- I can't wait to meet
your wife though man.
- No but it's fact.
Both of us didn't get there
because of some unbelievable
natural giftedness we have
that just produced success.
Right?
I don't measure myself
against other people because
they've got gifts that
are different than mine.
- Yeah.
- Raise your standard.
- Apple at the core, its
core value is that we believe
that people with passion
can change the world for the better.
- Not one drop of my self
worth depends on your
acceptance of me.
(slow piano music)
- If you guys liked this
video, check out the one I did
on the five morning routines
that will transform your life.
It's right next to me.
I think you're going to enjoy it.
Continue to believe
and I'll see you there.
- I'll just be honest.
How many of you all get up and
you just get your day started.
You don't have it written down.
You don't have a strategy.
You don't have a real plan.